ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
อากาศก็วีดีโอนี้ก็เป็นมีอินเนอร์ Class
นาอากรรมผู้หญิงแล้วก็
หนูฝาค่ะเย้ๆๆๆ
โครมาคะวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันพฤหัสบดีค่ะ
วันพฤหัสบดีค่ะวันพฤหัสที่เท่าไหร่คะวัน
พฤหัสบดีที่
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือน
มกราคม
ข่าเดือนมกราคมเป็นเอาเป็นเดือนที่เท่า
ไหร่คะอ่ะ
คนเดือนมกราคมเป็นเดือนที่ 1 หากมีผชอะไร
คะ
ปีพต 2
2556  5 ค่ะปีคศอะไรคะ
ปีคศ 2
2022 เนาะแล้วเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันพุธค่ะวันพุธที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันพุธที่ 19 เดือน
เดือนมกราคม
ปีพตต
2565 ปีคศ
2  022 ค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะอ่ะ
เตือนพรุ่งนี้วันศุกร์ค่ะวันศุกร์ที่เท่า
ไหร่คะวันศุกร์ที่
เดือน
มกราคม
ปีพตต
2565 ปีคศ
022 ค่ะค่ะน้องวันนี้ก็วันพฤหัสแล้วเนาะ
แล้วตอนนี้เย้เย้เวลากี่โมงแล้วคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา
เที่ยง
เที่ยงกี่นาทีคะครูฟ้า
12:38
นาทีค่ะแล้วก็เป็นตอนกลางวันสมัยเป็นตอน
เที่ยงน้องกลางวันครูฟ้ากินข้าว
อีกแล้วนะคะ
ครูฟ้ากินข้าวแล้วค่ะกินข้าวแล้วมากิน
พิซซ่าโอกูมากินพิซซ่า
ป้านาหาโดมิโน
ผู้หญิงตรงนี้นะผู้หญิงก็กินข้าวแล้วค่ะ
กินเสร็จแล้วแล้วก็คิดผู้หญิงก็กินพิซซ่า
เหมือนครูฟ้า
พิซซ่าปลายจากที่สร้างกินแบบอิ่มมากรู้
สึก
อิ่มแล้วก็นั่งแล้วก็พูดพูดพูดเนี่ยไม่
โอเคก็เลยคิดกินอิ่มมากๆถ้าพูดวีดีโอนี้
เสร็จคิดคิดจะไปออกกำลังกาย
ผู้หญิงจะไปออกกำลังกาย
ผู้หญิงจะออกกับกลายอะไรอ่ะ
เดินค่ะคุณฟ้า
เดินหรอ
อันนี้ก็เดินไหมผู้ชายคนเนี้ย
เดินจะเดินเดินๆเพราะว่าผู้หญิงคิดคิดว่า
ต้อง
เดินมากๆสมัยอย่างต่างโทรศัพท์เนี่ยมันก็
จะมีอย่างนี้ใช่ไหมว่า 1 วัน 1 วันเนี่ย
เราเดินเท่าไหร่
คุณก็คิด 1 วันหญิงจะเดินไปจะเดิน
10,000 นะคะ
ส่วนหนึ่งสเต็ป
เดินเดินเดินออกกำลังกายใช่ไหมสบายสบาย
กินเสร็จแล้วก็เดินการเดินเดินๆ
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยออกกำลังกายเนี่ยเดินครูฟ้า
ออกกำลังกายไหมคะ
ครูฟ้าออกกำลังกายค่ะ
กูฟ้าออกกำลังกายเดิน
ไม่อ้าวกูฟามไม่เดินไม่เดินช้า
วิ่ง
วิ่งหรอ
วิ่งมั้ยน้อง
ไม่อยู่วิ่ง
ครูฟ้าไม่ออกกำลังไม่วิ่งทำให้ออกกำลัง
กายวิ่ง
เออครูฟ้า
เบลล์
โอลิมปิคเร็ว
ผู้หญิง
คู่ฟ้า
อันนี้มันน้ำยา
โอยใช้ดัมเบลเหรอเนี่ยไม่ใช่อันนี้อันนี้
อันนี้ดัมเบลใช่ไหมเอามึงเนี่ยเดี๋ยว
ยกดัมเบลแต่ของครูมาเนี่ย
ยกน้ำหนัก
ยกดัมเบล
ไม่มีค่ะไม่มีดัมเบลผู้หญิงผู้หญิงยก
ดัมเบลเนาะ to จริงๆที่ Condominium
คอนโดมิเนียมเนี่ย
ที่ Condominium ครูหญิงเนี่ยมีดัมเบล
มีดัมเบลนะ
6  Ant โห
ม 6 ไอ้ทรายผู้หญิงเนี่ยมีดัมเบลอ่า
นําเบลสองอันเนี่ย
หนักเนาะ 1
1 กิโลกรัม
แต่ก็ไม่เห็นดัมเบลป๋า
2 อันหนักหนักเท่าไหร่
3 กิโลกรัม 3 กิโลกรัมนำจ่ายค่ะแล้วก็มี
อีก 2 อัน
น่าเศร้า
อีก 2 อันหนักเท่าไหร่ 5 กิโลกรัมมั้ยมี 1
2  3  4  5  6  6 อันแต่ว่าถ้ากิโลกรัม
เนี่ยไม่ได้
แต่คุยก็ยกนะยกดัมเบล
ฮือฮือฮา
อุ้ยดีมากผู้หญิงแผนครูฟ้าไม่ใช่ไหมครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยอ่าไม่
วิ่ง
ไม่ยกดัมเบลไม่
ไม่เดิน
คะเพราะครูฟ้าเนี่ย
กระโดดเชือกไม่มีเชือกมันก็แบบ
กระโดดเชือกครูฟ้ากระโดดเชือกออกกำลังกาย
ไว้คู่ไฟล์ชอบกระโดดเชือกนะคะ
มีเชือกใช่ไหมว่าจะมีเชือกแล้วก็กระโดด
กระโดดกระโดดกระโดดเธอสนุกมากโครงฟ้า
กระโดดเชือกเนี่ย 1  2  3 เท่าไหร่กี่
ครั้ง
ประมาณ 1  200 ได้มั้งเมื่อก่อน
ว่าชอบออก
มากระโดดเชือกประมาณครึ่งชั่วโมงอ่ะ
กระโดดเชือก 200 ครั้งเนาะประมาณ
30 นาทีใช่ไหมครูฟ้าครึ่งชั่วโมงโม้เก่ง
นะครูหญิงเนี่ยกระโดดเชือกเนี่ยไม่ได้ผู้
หญิงไม่ชอบหรอทำไมยังไงไม่เข้าใจทำยังไง
ลิงกระโดดเชื่อมกำลังกายเนี่ยไม่ได้
ไม่นะได้ใส่จากลูกค้าออกกำลังกายกระโดด
เชือกใช่ไหมอ่ะฝากกระโดดอีเรือมาแล้วชอบ
ใส่ไหมค่ะโยคะล่ะคะครูฟ้าออกกรรมออกกำลัง
กายด้วยโยคะมั้ยดูคะอยู่คะหรอไม่อยู่คะมี
ความเล่นโยคะไม่เป็นอยู่คะไม่เจ็บอ่ะไม่
เข้าใจอ่ะผู้หญิงเหมือนกันแต่ก็
ไม่ได้ออกกำลังกายแบบไม่ได้เล่นโยคะเนาะ
เรียนน่าจะเล่นโยคะไหม
อันนี้ครูฟ้าอาจจะชอบอะไรคะผู้หญิงเต้น
แอโรบิค e&o มาหนึ่งสองอึกหนึ่งสองอีก
หนึ่ง
ในโรเบิครูฟ้าออกกำลังกายเต้นแอโรบิคไหม
คะ
เมื่อก่อน
เมื่อก่อนตอนเด็กๆก็เด็กอายุ
13 มั้งครูฟ้า
ครูป๊าอายุ 13 ปีเนาะเต้นแอโรบิคๆคะ 1
ชั่วโมงหนึ่งชั่วโมงไหมเต้นแอโรมา 40
นาทีค่ะอ๋ออ๋อไม่ไม่ถึง 1 ชั่วโมงถึง
หนึ่งชั่วโมง
อีกประมาณ 40 นาทีก็จะมีแอโรบิคมีเพลง
โอเคโอเคโอเคอ่าเต้นแอโรบิคบิกแต่ไม่ชอบ
อะไร
ไม่ไม่ชอบแต่เคยเต้นแอโรบิคนี้ก็มีผู้
หญิงอีกแมวขี้ล่ะญาติไม่เข้าใจสเต็ปเท้า
เซ็ปต์เท้าสมัยหนึ่งสองสามสี่ทางผู้หญิง
เนี่ยเต้นแอโรบิคใช่ไหมคะเท้าเนี่ยสเต็ป
เท้าโอเคมือแอดไม่ได้
ถ้ามือ
โอเค
เท้าไม่ได้
ใช่ๆต้องเก่งนะเต้นแอโรบิคหรอแต่ครูฟ้าก็
เต้นแอโรบิคเนาะเมื่อก่อนเมื่อคืนซะอยู่
แล้วอันนี้ล่ะคะปั่นจักรยานครูฟ้าออก
กำลังกายปั่นจักรยานไหม
ฟ้าชอบปั่นจักรยานฮะหนู
นาทีคะ
ปั่นจักรยานกี่นาทีถ้าเป็นไม่ใช่จักรยาน
ที่เป็นเหมือนอะไรอ่ะที่เป็นแม่ชีนก็เป็น
จากไหนล่ะ
อ่าจริงๆนะคะ
1 ชัวร์ปั่นจักรยานแบบนี้ใช่ไหมปั่น
จักรยานแบบนี้ปั่นจักรยานเท่าไหร่นะคะ
เวลา
ประมาณ 1 ชั่วโมงครึ่งค่ะโห
คุณหนึ่งชั่วโมงครึ่ง
ฮวกงานนะอ้าว่าตอนหรอปั่นจักรยานใช่ไหม
ที่บ้านแล้วจะมีที่ปั่นจักรยานอากาศเย็น
หน้าหนาวลมเย็น
ฟ้าก็เลยชอบใช่ไหมผู้อ่านชอบใช่ไหมปั่น
จักรยาน
รอบมากทำก่อนผู้หญิงปั่นจักรยานไหมคะ
มายรู้หญิงผู้หญิงปั่นจักรยานแบบนี้ครับ
ฟ้า
นับไหนฮะอะที่กูฝาไม่ชอบคะ
ปั่นจักรยาน
อ่ะ
แบบนี้เขาก็เริ่มปั่นจักรยานนะคนไทยให้มี
อีกเนี่ยปั่นจักรยานแบบนี้ค่ะในฟิตเนสใน
ยิมเนาะอันนี้โปโอเค
รยาในคิดเด็ดสายสายๆหรือว่าแบบนี้สมัยนี้
ก็เป็นปั่นจักรยานในฟิตเนสเนี้ยอ้ะได้ค่ะ
เอากูป่าก็ปั่นจักรยานเนาะค่ะวันนี้นะคะ
ครูฟ้า
อันนี้คนไทยเด็กวิดพื้นน้ำครูฟ้าวิดพื้น
ไหมคะ
ไม่หากไม่วิดพื้น
ไม่ได้นะได้ประมาณ 5 ครั้งหนึ่งสองสามสิบ
เกาะ
นี้ต้องแต่แหงนใช่ไหมแค่เนี่ยต้องแบบแข็ง
แรงน้องอะไรอ่ะนะผู้หญิงได้ไหมหรือไม่ได้
เก่งก็วิดพื้นเนี่ยไม่ได้นะต้องกับโกหก
เก่งมากๆนะคะสายมีแต่ไม่ได้ออกแล้วถ้าอัน
นี้นะคะครูฟ้านี่คุณฟ้ารู้ไหมออกกำลังกาย
ท่าอะไร
ไม่รู้ค่ะอันนี้ออกกำลังกายอะไรคะอันนี้
คือกระโดดตบ
กระโดดพบจ่ายสายเออหนึ่งสองสามสิบท่า
กระโดดตบอันนี้ได้สเต็ปที่ 1 แล้วก็สเต็ป
ที่ 2 เหนื่อยไหมคะ R กระโดดตบ
ออกจากลูกค้าได้ไหมกระโดดตบๆหากระโดดโต๊ะ
เมื่อก่อนวอร์มร่างกายใช่ไหมก็จะกระโดดตบ
ใจแบบนี้หรอก
แต่ไม่ชอบนะไม่ชอบเหนื่อยไม่เหนื่อยผู้
หญิงล่ะคะผู้หญิงได้ไหมกระโดดตบได้ผู้
หญิงออกกำลังกายกระโดดตบ
กระโดดตบแบบนี้นะคะได้
ดีนะคิดว่าน่าจะประมาณ 20 ครั้งหนึ่งสอง
สามเนี่ยประมาณ 20 ครั้ง OK ขอ
พรเหนื่อยนะมันเหนื่อยหน่อย
แต่ว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยครูฟ้าบอกว่าวิ่งใช่ไหม
คะวิ่งเนี่ยครูฟ้าไม่เอาสมัยไม่ออกกำลัง
กายไม่วิ่งครูฟ้าวิ่งแบบนี้ไหมคะอันนี้ก็
วิ่งเหมือนกันนะแต่วิ่งในวิ่งบนลู่วิ่ง
แบบนี้ที่ฟิตเนสที่ที่ยิม
โอเคนะ
พี่ฟิตเนสกูว่าโอเคค่ะนาทีค่ะคือสาว
วิ่งวิ่งวิ่งวิ่งกี่นาที
ประมาณ 30 นาที
โอเคนะดีนั้น
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยวิ่ง 30 นาทีเนาะทรายปลาวิ่ง
ดูซีรี่มิกซ์
เทคนิคดูซีรีย์แล้วก็วิ่งวิ่งวิ่ง
น่าจะได้ออกกำลังกายนานๆๆ
แล้วครูฟ้าออกกำลังกายอย่างอื่นอีกไหมคะ
ก็มีกุมภาเนี่ยออกกำลังอายอย่างอื่นค่ะมี
เต้น
เต้นแต่ไม่ใช่แอโรบิคสวยไม่ใช่เต้น
แอโรบิคเต้นฮิปฮอปอะไรอย่างเงี้ยเต้น
ป๊อปปิ้ง
เบรคแดนซ์หรือเปล่าอะไรประมาณนี้ค่ะว่า
ชอบเต้น
มากช่วยครูฟ้าเต้นเต้นเต้นๆกี่นาที
กุมภาพันธ์เคยเต้น 8 ชั่วโมงค่ะฮะ
เต้นกับเพื่อนนะ 8 ชั่วโมงชั่วโมง
โอเคไหมคะ
เหนื่อย
เหนื่อยแต่ว่าตอนนั้นมีโชว์มีเราต้องไป
ชวนก็เลยต้อง 48 ชั่วโมงค่ะมี
คอมเต้น 8 ชั่วโมงแล้วก็ที่กูป่าชอบนะคะ
ก็คือ
แบดมินตันอ๋อ
เล่นแบดมินตันออกกำลังกายกี่ชั่วโมงครู
ฟ้าเล่นแบบมินตันอ่ะแบดมินตันก็ประมาณ 1
ชั่วโมง
ฉันดึกเนาะ 1 ชั่วโมงหนึ่งชั่วโมงโอเค
แล้วนะ
มันกูฟ้าเนี่ยเล่นแบดมินตันจะไม่มีผู้
หญิงไม่ได้
เอนไม่ได้ยังไม่พูดเหรอวิ่ง
อันนี้มีลูกใช่ไหมคะแล้วก็มีไม้แบต
ลูกอยู่ที่ดี้งั้นผู้หญิง
นิวสปอร์ตไม่โอเคค่ะนักเรียน
จักรยาน
โอเคเดินก็โอเคเธอผู้หญิง Under ไม่ใช่
ไหมเพราะว่าแบบเวลาที่ออกกำลังกายน้องโดย
ทั่วไปแวะบางคนเนี่ยก็อาจจะวิ่งใช่ไหม
วิ่งบางคนก็ยกดัมเบล
เนาะบางคนก็เดิน
ใส่ว่าคนก็กระโดดเชือกนี้ครูฟ้าใสกูป่าว
เนี่ยเชือกนะคะหรือว่าบางคนก็เล่นโยคะใช่
ไหมคะเล่นโยคะอ่าบางคนก็เต้นแอโรบิคหนู
บิดอันนี้อะไรคะอันจักรยานค่ะหลายค่ะแล้ว
ก็
วิดพื้น
กระโดดตบสายกระโดดตบว่าบางคนก็วิ่งสมัย
ไหนฟิตเนสวิ่งในพูด
หรือว่าเต้นใช่ไหมเต้น
เต้นเหมือนครูฟ้าแล้วก็แบดมินตันใช่ไหมคะ
ออกกำลังกายน้องผู้หญิงนะแม่บ้านเดินนะ
เดินไหมคะครูฟ้าเนี่ยเต้นเต้นนักเรียนออก
กำลังกายยังไงก็คอมเม้นท์บอกได้นะคะใส่
แล้วค่ะส่วนวันนี้เราสองคนก็ไปก่อนเนาะ
แล้วเจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้านะคะบ๊ายบายให้
สวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ